i feel like you were kind of the first
dude i can kind of really remember at
least one of the first dudes that were
really
implementing i guess what we'll call
like
r and b [ __ ] but
from a street angle
where it was kind of blurring the lines
of hip-hop and rb like i really kind of
feel like you were
on the forefront of that man yeah i
ain't gonna lie like i came home in like
2013 2014
wasn't nobody really doing that [ __ ] and
i got rebooked again because i was just
[ __ ] around just yeah not doing what
i was supposed to do and i got locked up
again and that mix of that fetty wap
came out on [ __ ] i'm like oh [ __ ]
somebody
somebody about to come [ __ ] that wave up
that i had you heard me yeah but it was
like
when i still i still had to like i don't
i don't know when i before i got booked
it was like i had [ __ ] rolling already
like shows i had features people was
[ __ ] with my sound already and then i
got locked up for like nine months eight
months that [ __ ] was it was like i was
thinking like damn it's over like that's
gonna slow me down right there's another
[ __ ] i'm hearing this on the right i'm
like this other [ __ ] just came and he
on the same wave i was on you feel me
i'm like damn it's over but that [ __ ]
ain't stop nothing though i mean i came
home
[ __ ] was even way bigger than it was
when i was first originally out there
like i had labels coming to [ __ ] with me
and everything i'm like i'm gonna pull
up you feel me that [ __ ] was different
and then i actually the person that
signed fetty wap was the person that
came to sign me orlando
mm-hmm so i was like
i'm thinking that the way it was gonna
be i'm thinking it was gonna be a little
awkward you feel me like damn this
[ __ ] he probably gonna think
like i'm trying to steal his sound and
[ __ ] and i've been doing this [ __ ]
but this [ __ ] was the most genuine
[ __ ] ever when i first met him fetty
yeah i just heard such great things
about fetty fetty the goat man shout out
to fetty man he put me on a whole bunch
of game as far as like the music
industry like how [ __ ] was gonna carry
he put me on like he told me how a whole
bunch of rappers was going to be before
i even got to do it like and i started
noticing this [ __ ] like this [ __ ] cuddy
put me on this [ __ ] a minute ago you
need to be really like trying to leech
off you
get when you get get what they can get
your clowning yeah that should be weird
yeah i feel like a lot of that probably
had to have happened to him because i
feel like at a certain point in time for
at least a year he was the hottest thing
moving yeah [ __ ] it bro cause when he
was opening for chris brown on tour
people were more excited and i swear to
god because i was at the radio station
giving away tickets to the chris brown
fetty wap tour and everyone was calling
out they weren't asking for chris brown
they were like yo when we want to go see
fetty wap and i'm like well you know
chris brown is gonna be there too they
didn't care
so he like he he was a superstar for you
know 12 months maybe two years i mean it
was a great 12 month run yeah the
craziest run